PROFESSOR: Hi, everyone.
Welcome back.
So today, we're going to take
a look at homogeneous equations
with constant coefficients,
and specifically, the case
where we have real roots.
And we'll start the
problem off by looking
at the equation x dot dot
plus 8x dot plus 7x equals 0.
And we're asked to find
the general solution
to this differential equation.
And then we also
have the question,
do all the solutions go to
0 as t goes to infinity?
And then for part B, we're
going to take a look at just
the differential equation
y dot equals negative k*y.
So this is the same
equation that we've
seen in past recitations.
And we're just going to show
that we can use this method
to solve this
differential equation
and obtain the same result.
And then lastly, we're asked,
or we're told that
we have eight roots
to an eighth-order differential
equation, negative 4,
negative 3, negative 2,
negative 1, 0, 1, 2, and 3.
And we're asked, what
is the general solution.
So why don't you take a moment
and try and work these problems
out, and I'll be
back in a minute.
Hi, everyone.
Welcome back.
OK, so we're asked to find the
general solution to x double
dot plus 8x dot
plus 7x equals 0.
And we see that this is
a differential equation,
it's linear, and it has
constant coefficients.
And whenever we have a
differential equation
that's linear with
constant coefficients,
one of the standard ways
to generate the solution is
to seek what sometimes
mathematicians call an ansatz,
but it's to try a solution
of the form x is equal
to a constant
times e to the s*t.
And if we substitute a
solution n of this form,
we see that taking the second
derivative of this function
pulls down two s's.
One derivative pulls down one s.
We have no derivatives here.
And we also have, on each
term, a factor of c times e
to the s*t.
And we want this to be 0.
So specifically, c e to the
s*t can't be 0 for all time.
So the only way
that this can hold
is if s squared plus
8s plus 7 equals 0.
So what this means is if
we choose s to solve this
polynomial, then x equals c e
to the s*t will be the solution.
And this will be the
solution for any constant c.
OK, so what are the roots
to this algebraic equation.
Well, we can factorize it.
The roots are going to be
negative 7 and negative 1.
And notice how
this whole process
has turned a differential
equation into a simpler
algebraic equation.
So if we can solve the
algebraic equation,
then we can solve the
differential equation.
OK, so the general solution.
Well, we've just shown that we
can take any constant times e
to the s*t, provided s is equal
to negative 1 or negative 7.
So the general solution is going
to be some constant, c_1, times
e to the minus t, plus c_2,
can be a different constant,
e to the minus 7t.
So notice how
there's two constants
in the final solution.
And the reason
there's two constants
is because we started out with
a second-order differential
equation.
So, in some sense,
for each order
of the differential equation,
we always have one constant.
It's almost as if for
each time we integrate,
we have a constant
of integration.
So at the end of the day,
we have two constants
in our general solution.
As part of part A, we're
also asked for any solution
to this differential
equation, does the solution
go to 0 as t goes to infinity?
Well, the general
solution has this form.
So for any constant c_1
and c_2, the solution
is c_1 e to the minus t
plus c_2 e to the minus 7t.
And we see that no matter
what c_1 and c_2 are,
this term, as t
goes to infinity,
is multiplied by e to the
minus t, which goes to 0.
And the second term
also goes to 0.
So as t goes to infinity,
both e to the minus t
and e to the minus
7t both go to 0.
So that means that
any constant times
e to the minus t plus
e to the minus 7t
must also go to 0.
So hence, x of t goes to
0 as t goes to infinity.
OK.
For part B, we have the
differential equation y dot
equals negative k*y.
And this is the first-order
linear differential equation
with constant coefficients.
And we're going to
use the same trick.
We let y is equal to
c times e to the s*t.
And we see that the
characteristic equation
in this case, it's
not a polynomial.
It's just s, s is
equal to negative k.
So we get y is equal to c e to
the negative k*t is the general
solution.
And this is exactly what we
had in previous recitations,
when we used, for example,
integrating factors
to solve this very same
differential equation.
So this just shows that
we can use the same method
to solve first-order linear
differential equations.
OK.
Now, lastly, we're
given eight roots
to an eighth-order
differential equation.
An eighth-order
differential equations
with constant coefficients.
So I'll just write
out the roots again.
So we're told the
roots are negative 4,
negative 3, negative 2,
negative 1, 0, 1, 2, and 3.
And in general, the solution
to an eighth-order differential
equation whose roots to the
characteristic polynomial
are negative 4 through 3,
the general solution, x of t,
is going to be a
constant c_1 times e
to the power of the first
root, which will be minus 4t,
plus c_2 e to the minus 3t.
And of course, we take different
constants for each term.
c_3 e to the minus 2t, plus
c_4 e to the minus t, plus c_5.
And now for this term,
it should be e to the 0t,
but e to the 0t is just 1.
So the zero root is just going
to give us a constant c_5.
And we have c_6 to the
t, plus c_7 e to the 2t.
And then plus c_8 e to the 3t.
So the solution has eight
terms and eight constants.
And just for fun, we can
ask, does every solution
to this differential equation
go to 0 as t goes to infinity.
And the answer is no.
In fact, although each
term with a negative root
does go to zero as
t goes to infinity,
there are three terms that
go to positive infinity
as t goes to infinity,
and there's one term
that just stays constant.
So in general, as t
grows, goes to infinity,
these terms will
become very large
and won't necessarily go to 0.
Well, they'll never go to 0.
So I'd just like
to conclude there,
and I'll see you next time.